Rogan experience time,
but another one that I remember early on
early on,
John Jones,
he wasn't anything bad.
It was for no,
maybe something like that.
I'm meeting them talking about shit and
I could talk about this now because it's
not no longer a banned substance.
UFC,
but like a talking about weed.
Yeah.
And was like,
yeah,
let's smoke bro.
He wasn't anything.
It wasn't anything and just going like,
he's like,
who's got wait?
I'm like,
oh Rogan's got it.
But he's in his hotel room and texting
you flip phone,
texting you back when it wasn't cool to
have like hip to have a flip phone.
What it was like,
that's all anybody had.
That's how long ago.
And then just go in like maybe it's that
and maybe it was early a iphone,
but like just going,
hey man,
are you up?
And you're like,
yeah,
I'm kind of tired.
Go to sleep.
And was like,
Fuck John.
I think he's doesn't want us up there.
And then be like,
no,
let's go.
He's got the weed.
Let's go.
Because some fan gave it to us,
right?
You had this fucking tin,
tin foil of weed and um,
and just knock on your door and you're
like,
what?
And you're like,
uh,
you retired?
And it was like,
um,
do you have that?
We'd like to come on,
I want to go to sleep.
It's like,
man,
John want to smoke?
And you're like,
you looked at us,
you open the door fully looked at me and
this young fighter and you're like,
come on in.
And we all smoked pot together and this
hotel room and fucking wherever it was,
I think Montreal,
Montreal.
And you're just a fun time.
And then seeing this guy move on to
become the baddest motherfucker on the
planet.
But we also had a conversation with him
about I wanted him to go to a different
camp.
That's right.
He was training in fucking youtube
videos in New York with his buddies in a
garage.
You too.
Good.
I'm Mike.
You should be in a real cash.
That's right.
We had that over weed in that hotel
room.
He's like,
you really think so?
I go,
I know.
So I know you only have a certain amount
of time in this thing.
I go and your time should be invested
with a real coach who's going to hone
your skills.
I go,
you can be an all time.
Great man.
Wow.
Yeah.
I remember telling him that and he's
like,
you really think so?
I go,
I know.
So I know.
So you,
you really got to move on.
I forgot about that part of it.
That how influential is out in the
fucking future of mixed martial arts.
I hope it helped.
I feel like I retain enough strength to
be good at what I need to.
So to burn yourself out.
I don't burn myself out,
you know,
because like the oldest people in the
world were an athlete,
you know,
and they're kind of people who didn't
burn themselves out too much.
So I,
my theory on longevity is like don't
overdo it.
I don't need to necessarily be
overtrained for what I do.
A lot of the skill.
A lot of the,
the winning that I do competitively is
from a skill.
It's not so much from being super strong
having crazy cardio.
It's making a choice about which wave,
how I'm gonna Approach and ride that
wave and I have to get two scores every
30 minutes when they compete.
So it's like I got this 30 minute window
I need to be ready for.
I don't need to be like in crazy,
crazy shape [inaudible].
So what is it that held other guys back
in the past?
I think there's a number of factors.
I think you have to naturally be really
competitive.
Like in your,
when you were born,
your home,
somehow you had to,
maybe you needed something to prove.
You know,
I,
I was Kinda like,
you know,
growing up I sort of looked back at it
and kind of laugh.
Like I maybe I couldn't get the girl I
liked because she liked an older guy or
you know,
I didn't have,
we didn't really have any money in my
family so I wanted to make some money.
I had an older brother who kind of
picked on me,
but I hung out with him and played
football with his friends that were all
three years older than me.
So I had to be strong,
you know,
I had to be tough and fast.
I had to be smart.
That's the case with a lot of guys,
older brothers,
they were brothers that they couldn't
really compete with them like this
motherfucker.
And so every night we would just eat
away at the end.
I think it,
I think it did and there was always
that,
you know,
my brother and I have,
I think we have a pretty good
relationship now and I don't think he
would disagree with me that we kind of
didn't get along for 20 years or more.
We shouldn't hate each other.
It's a long time.
And then the other thing is about wally,
I hate trashing law but also kind of
loved trashing wildly,
uh,
is they have a lot of money to pay
celebrities to tweet ads for awhile way
basically Gaga being one of them.
Right.
And you heard this story,
uh,
so she's tweeted a bunch of wally ads
and I noticed that while she's a brand
ambassador for awhile,
a tweeting ads about how much she loves
her Huawei phone.
If you look in the details of the tweet,
it's always via twitter for iphone and
it's like whatever.
She can use an iphone.
I don't care,
but I thought it was funny so I just
tweeted it.
It's very funny.
It blew up and uh,
I had while way reach out to me like,
how did you find this?
How did you know,
where did you,
is this a mistake?
Like,
could this be a pr?
has this ever malfunction?
I'm like,
no,
this is,
that's how twitter works.
Like you can see the data.
It's clearly an iphone.
And I thought that was,
that's my screenshot.
And so,
uh,
not only did Gaga Dope Bloch Gal Godot,
the fucking wonder woman lady.
Yeah.
Wonder woman,
wonder woman,
you fucking fake from an iphone.
It's just funny because look at the
picture of her lyrics.
She blocked you.
Not only did she blocked me,
but wowway since then has tweeted they
deleted like her latest tweets and
repost them from an android phone and
she's tweeted from android phone ever
since.
I'll give her respect for that.
Well,
they probably told her you're gonna lose
all that cash is no way she's tweeting
like she has a team.
I get it,
but like whoever was on her team
tweeting from an iphone,
like the fact that she blocked you.
Those hilarious.
That's gross.
I thought it was really didn't do
anything.
No,
I didn't.
I think I tagged her in and she probably
was just getting barraged by like people
going,
well you're using an APP like an iphone.
Like why I'm I think event.
It was like a year later she unblocked
me.
It was really funny.
She unblocked me.
Thanks.
Go.
So he actually changed his position
slightly because when he ran for
president he said,
not only am I against marijuana being
illegal at a federal level,
I wouldn't even let the individual
states decide whether or not
they want legal marijuana.
So in other words,
he would prosecute the states like
Colorado and California that have legal
marijuana using federal law.
And right there he softened his position
slightly and he said,
well,
leave it up to the states and let them
decide.
So anything that's because he knows
he'll never be president.
No,
I think he still wants to be president.
There's no fucking way.
I think he's gonna run again.
No,
I don't know if he's going to run in 20
slash 20,
but 20,
24.
No,
I'm serious.
First of all,
the uh,
the odds of that guy's going to make it
eight more years with that fair point.
Morbidly obese carcass.
He's moving his hand around with it.
Need get a stapler.
Didn't he get his stomach fucking suit?
You know,
somebody pointed that out.
I didn't know that.
I never saw those stories.
I'm not denying that it's true,
but I just never heard it.
But if he did didn't work while I had a
friend who ate through two of those,
he,
uh,
when you're a d,
that's what I'm saying anyway,
about food.
He's addicted to food that's like,
this is unquestionably,
he's an addict.
Do you think nobody said that to him in
his life or.
And I look,
look how much thinner he go.
Okay.
And he did this.
Oh,
I guess he did this before the
presidential race because he wanted to
make it,
but then he got fat again.
Yeah.
So he was wrote ton before.
He was like a bag of water before and
then you know,
he,
he trimmed himself down.
Yeah.
And it's funny because I don't think in
any way he realizes the hypocrisy of
having his own,
um,
you know,
issue with food and he would argue,
hey man,
listen,
I'm going to eat what I want it to
freedom choice.
But when it comes to freedom for
somebody to decide to tweak their
consciousness slightly,
all of a sudden he says,
you shouldn't be allowed to do that.
Well,
that's where it's preposterous.
The idea that,
you mean even with what he said about
alcohol didn't make any sense.
Like,
what'd you mean?
The alcohol illegal,
what we try to read,
it's called prohibition.
Okay.
But let's pretend that you had some sort
of an ability to keep that from going
sideways.
Again,
let's start from the beginning.
Would you want alcohol to be legal or
not?
If you could wave your hand and and
there would be no more problems that are
alcohol associated,
would you do that and make it illegal
versus give a grown adult the
possibility of deciding whether or not
they want to drink or not drink?
Yeah.
He's not being consistent and his logic.
That's the point is that he's willing to
say I'm thinking about donuts,
but he even.
He even mentioned prohibition there,
but that makes my point,
not his point.
Yes,
because that's when the mafia got
incredibly powerful because you pushed
all the alcohol sales underground and
they got all the power and the money as
a result of it and that's when crime is
shot through the roof,
so if you want to decrease violent crime
and the drug war,
one of the most transformative
moments of my life was when I met spot
many in person,
which is one of the legged robots in
Boston dynamics for the first time when
I met them,
met that little fella there was.
I know exactly how it works.
I know exactly how every aspect of it
works.
It's just a dumb robot,
but when I met him and he got up and he
looked at me,
there it is right there.
Have you seen a dance now?
Yeah.
The dance.
The dance is crazy.
It's but see,
it's not crazy on the technical side.
It's engineered.
It's obvious.
It's programmed,
but it's crazy to watch like,
wow,
there's something.
The reason that moment was
transformative because I know exactly
how it works and yet by watching it
something about the feeling of it,
you're like,
this thing is alive
and there was this terrifying moment.
Not Terrifying,
terrifying and appealing where this is
the future,
right?
Like this thing,
like this thing represents some future
that is totally that we don't cannot
understand.
Just like a future in the 18th century
of a future with planes and smartphones
was something you could understand that
this thing,
that little dog could have had a a human
consciousness in it.
That was the feeling I had and I know
exactly how it works.
There's nothing close to the
intelligence,
but it just gives you this picture of
what the possibilities are of these
living creatures and I think that's what
people feel when they see Boston
dynamics will call awesome.
This thing running around is they don't
care about the technicalities and how
far away we are.
They see it,
look,
this thing is pretty human and the
possibilities of human like things that
supercede humans and can evolve and
learn so quickly,
exponentially fast is this terrifying
frontier that that really makes us think
as it did for me.
I'm sure a bull rider would look at free
soloing.
It'd be like,
what a crazy dude.
You know,
everybody looks at another sport and
they're like,
that's great,
and honestly I look at fighting and I'm
like us,
and he was totally outrageous.
I'm like,
why would you want some other dude beat
you to death in the cage?
I'm like,
that's crazy outrageous.
It is outrageous,
but if you can get good enough where you
can avoid getting the knowledge and then
the tool to land the damage,
it's kind of the same.
But even landing the damage to a certain
extent,
you're like,
oh,
you're hurting somebody else for the
pleasure of the crowd.
You're like,
that's Kinda messed up.
You know,
it's a very weird feeling.
Knocking someone out is one of the
weirdest feelings because a part of you
is happy that it's not you,
but part of you is like looking down
with that guy that's just got flatlined
and you're like,
Whoa,
that could have been made.
And how much to fighters?
Like,
hold back,
you know,
because I feel like you kind of have to
like go to the death,
but then if you actually like punch
somebody so hard they died or something.
I mean obviously you'd feel horrible or
it will.
You don't look back at all.
But that's what I'm saying.
But.
So it's like you don't hold back at all,
but then if you actually killed
somebody,
wouldn't you feel horrible?
It's very rare that someone dies in
mixed martial arts.
Believe it or not.
Well,
yeah.
No,
I mean I know that,
but it's possible.
Yeah,
definitely.
And it has happened and it's sort of
like it has happened very,
very rarely in mixed martial arts.
Never in the UFC,
but in boxing it happens more often and
one of the reasons why it happens more
often in boxing because you're only
punching in mma,
you're taking people down.
People are tapping out because they're
paying weird grades.
Yeah.
Well,
it's also there's more options to defend
yourself.
You're not just getting battered against
the ropes.
They're also nowadays much better at
stopping a fight when a fighter's
clearly compromised when they're.
They're really fucked up.
In the old days,
they used to let guys just get battered
box.
That doesn't sit well with me.
I'm just like,
ah,
yeah,
but that's what I'm not a fighter.
Well,
that's the thing about climbing is
there's this real elemental appeal to
just you and the mountain and it's
nature and it's beautiful and it's very
peaceful and calm.
It's like so different than having
thousands of people screaming at you as
you punch someone in the face over and
over.
It was like,
dude,
that's just not.
My scene was like 2017.
Halloween.
I was a 400 pound stretched to pass a
skeleton.
Oh my gosh.
This fancy dress party in it.
I'm looking around and I'm thinking,
these are all young kids compared to me.
I'm 30 and I felt like I was the oldest
guy in there like 29.
It was like,
why am I doing here?
He says,
what you want for your life full of
yourself.
This is not me a number.
How many people told me before this
I was going wrong was doing.
You need to act out your life.
You can only change your life if you
want to change it.
And I left and everyone said,
are you going home early?
He said,
yeah.
I left at 9:00.
I went home and I got back home.
I didn't say anything to the Y,
but it went straight upstairs into a
dark room
and I took the cheap,
had skeleton suit off and I sat there
and I got on my knees and I was praying
and begging God to help me
know.
At this point I'd never.
I've never begged or cry to God to help
maybe for her.
I prayed a lot all my life,
but I'd never been in this physical
state before.
I can feel tears running down my face.
My chest was wet with tears because I
knew I couldn't do it on my own.
It wasn't possible for me because I
tried and tried and tried and ended up
back in Nepal,
back drinking.
I almost accepted that that was going to
be my fate and alcoholic.
So it was on my knees in his bedroom.
Um,
after praying for about 10 minutes,
I got up and I felt the weight of the
world was lifted off my shoulders.
And for the first time in years I knew
it was going to make a comeback.
And I called.
My wife has said Paris,
Paris.
She said,
well,
she followed was drunk coming home from
the pope.
I said,
Monday morning I started to regain
mission to try and get the heavyweight
championship of the world book.
She said,
yeah,
because before this,
every time I'd have a beer,
I'd come back and I'm going to be the
heavyweight champion of the world again,
because it was.
It was the alcohol talking,
so I was like the money called Wolf a
thousand on this.
This sheep had Korea to that.
I was living on the past thinking about
years before glory days and after this
prayer.
Opposite,
right?
This has got to be.
She didn't believe me one second,
but even when I speak to her now,
she says,
that night you told me that.
She said a year and a difference,
and you've always swimming cap on.